we're now learning the full scope of the
absurdity of this rally we've been
discussing donald trump's el paso texas
build the wall rally on monday night
I've already told you some examples of
why this is just so wacky and why
riddled and problematic number one is
that Donald Trump had previously said
that El Paso is a very dangerous city a
border city when the truth of course is
that El Paso is one of the safest cities
of its size in the United States it was
safe before a little bit of border
fencing was put up and it remained safe
after that bit of border fencing was put
up but Donald Trump choosing to say it's
an incredibly dangerous place and it
proves why we need the wall we already
talked today about this assault on a BBC
cameraman just moments after Donald
Trump again slammed the media during the
speech we also have discussed the kind
of hilarity
maybe contrast is a better way to say it
of Donald Trump talking about yes the
wall is definitely getting built on
Monday night at this rally as
Republicans were in the process of
agreeing with Democrats in principle to
a deal that has no substantive law
border wall funding but a sort of
billion dollar handout for some bollards
on a measly 55 miles of the border so
now we get to just a kind of more
cartoonish hilarious Trump lie it's kind
of like the sequel to the entire
inauguration crowd Fiasco from Donald
Trump's 2017 inauguration during the
rally in El Paso Texas
two nights ago Donald Trump bizarrely
claimed that exceptions had been made by
the El Paso Fire Department to allow
even more people into the building than
the number that would normally be
allowed presumably by the fire code this
is so specific and so pointless and so
untrue but for some weird reason Trump
chose to concoct this lie let's take a
look at that moment from the speech
there's never been if you would say
as an example that tonight 69 thousand
people signed up to be here now the
arena holds eight thousand and thank you
Fire Department they got in about ten
Thank You fire department so anyway
that's just not true the El Paso Fire
Department has now commented on this
because if there's an allegation made
that the fire department allowed 25
percent more people than should safely
be allowed into the building that's
that's a real problem right and the El
Paso Fire Department has said no we
didn't do anything to allow more people
into the arena than it's meant to hold
or more people than the facility is
permitted to allow but here's where it
gets even wackier the el paso fire
department was there and they said the
capacity of the arena is 6500 not 8,000
as Donald Trump claimed the actual
attendance of the event was also 6500
not 10,000 as Donald Trump said why does
Donald Trump keep lying about crowd
sizes and a big part of this entire
thing his this fixation on crowd size
seems to be that Trump wanted his thing
to be bigger than bado O'Rourke's he
doesn't like the idea of bid O'Rourke
having a bigger thing than Trump has so
when it became clear that bethe
O'Rourke's rally to even call it that is
maybe not even the right term but the
rally in which beta or ork participated
had between 10 and 15 thousand people
Trump all of a sudden felt like the size
of his thing was being put to shame with
only 6,500 so he just makes up that
8,000 is the number of people that would
normally be allowed in 10,000 is what we
had but who cares right that's the this
is the distraction I want to talk about
Donald Trump's obvious and brazen lies
but at the same time a bigger crowd
doesn't prove who has better ideas or
the right ideas or the smarter followers
this is a debate that only a very petty
man who just lies is even interested in
having and I think that that's the most
disturbing thing of all let me know what
you think is
I'm Donald Trump lying about the size of
his thing I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the
show is on Twitter at David Pakman show
one of today's sponsors Prez aback is
offering you some free stuff that I want
to tell you about spresso box is based
in New York City they help keep guys
wardrobes fresh without breaking the
bank
because when you become a member of
spresso box each month you'll get a new
box sent to your door
filled with five or six stylish
hand-picked accessories and pieces of
clothing for men it includes high end
socks neckties really nice sunglasses
wallets watches bracelets high-quality
pens and hair combs it's really classy
stuff that makes it easy to put a little
more pop into your wardrobe without
having to spend a ton of money a
subscription is just 25 bucks a month
but your new box every single month is
guaranteed to have items with a combined
value of over $100 a couple of the
things I got are a really nice money
clip a pocket square and some great
socks go check out the different things
that they put in their monthly boxes
they have a lot of really nice-looking
stuff
everyone in our audience can get one
month totally free when you click the
link underneath this video and use the
promo code Pakman that's PA que ma N